no no sorry go to thumbnail ah what's
going on picture on ejects and the
beginning part of this video YouTube how
y'all doing are you guys Greg Alba here
John here so today we're going to cover
the top movie news of the week not a
whole lot of things that we you know
it's just like a lot of them are like
updates when we're looking at the
articles or updates throughout the week
of what's been going on a lot of things
that we've already covered so many new
things to talk about America's birthday
next week that's what everybody's mostly
folks all people really give two craps
about but we wanted to talk about one
very specific thing before we go into
that by the time this video is up we
will probably be watching baby driver
into theaters we'd like to keep our
movie reviews for Sunday's like
throughout the week it's reactions and
occasionally another discussion video
but let's keep our reviews for a movie
news for Sunday release so we'll be
having a baby Trevor review coming up
keep a lookout for that shooting it
right after anyway top story the one
main story this week here it is matt
reeves director of the war for the
planet of the apes is saying that the
next batman movie will be a new are
driven detective film something that i
think a lot of fans of the whining here
for a long time I personally have stated
for quite a while now that one element
I've been wanting from a Batman film is
not only the heavy martial arts aspect
which is what we got with Batman V
Superman the one thing one of the few
things movie got where I was a heavy
martial arts Batman but also really
getting a detective and he's called the
dark detective for a reason we need the
detective side in there and now we're
finally getting and John Stark the court
that he said one of the reasons I was
drawn to the Batman is that I had a
similar obsession in Batman when I was
younger I thought I had with plenty
mm-hmm
which I was also obsessed Errol L
emotionally between Caesar and Batman
make sense why zoom in there in that
they're both tortured and trying to sort
of grapple within themselves to try and
do the right
seeing in a very important perfect and
to some degree corrupt world it's really
that emotionally that I'm interested
okay here's the part that everyone's
been flipping bottles about in all of my
films what I try to do in an almost
Hitchcockian sense oh you guys are no no
Alfred Hitchcock was a very famous
director yeah is use the camera and use
the storytelling so that you become the
character then you emphasize at that
point of view there's a chance to do it
almost the large driven detective
version of Batman that's a point of view
driven and the point of yeah right in a
very very powerful way and hopefully
it's going to connect with you to what's
going on inside of his head and inside
of his heart that sounded sounding like
a good idea yeah I really feel that you
know like okay I'm gonna get back on BBS
saga has problems I really we've not
done that enough yeah we need to keep
reminding everybody that we did like
that maybe he didn't like this room
really but I whenever people ask me what
my favorite Batman movie is I might
answer tends to be I think the best
Batman film is the Dark Knight but I
think the best Batman story is Batman
Begins because that's the one where you
really get to know Bruce Wayne who
Batman is
and his point of view towards life and
is it's really just all about births in
that movie they could have called that
movie all about Bruce won and the Dark
Knight makes the story something bigger
and more scopic whereas Batman Begins so
also has all that stuff in the narrows
and all that some of the hatbox and it
feels a bit more comic with Gotham yeah
and I think what I'm hearing Matt Reeves
say here it is perfect because it wasn't
until I saw war for the Planet of the
Apes that I thought this guy can
definitely do the Batman because I
always thought Matt Reeves is a fine
choice but it was when I saw war when I
was like yeah this guy is gonna deliver
if he's absolutely right about what he's
talking about with the parallels between
Caesar and Batman these both tortured
souls who are constantly trying to do
the right thing and of course having the
noir cent I mean the Batman's gonna talk
about this Oman yeah sorry your jig is
up the jig is up Joker
to face you've got half a face and half
a man or whatever the hell uh new offers
would say never I'm gonna leave it down
the best they got the improv oh yeah
sorry we leave the 30s in rum to me
bucko yeah well hearing what are you
saying here about capturing it from the
perspective of Batman I mean that's a
look obviously the most logical thing
you could do when you're calling a film
the Batman toe but one thing Batman
Begins was was it was really about Bruce
Wayne and not really about it's about
him becoming Batman in this film he will
be an established Batman already it's
not going to be an origin tale so I
think it would be very interesting to
see that side of him where I feel like
we'll probably get a lot more of Batman
being Batman and being Detective Batman
whereas Batman Begins and even The Dark
Knight Rises was heavy was much heavier
on Bruce Wayne Arena more than Batman
arena and so I think that's what I I
believe he is implying that he will be
focusing a lot more on when he's on the
streets taking now criminals having to
do nasty criminai how to do like the
nasty vigilante work I think Matt Reeves
will be able to capture that perfectly
in a very haunting way because I think
that's one thing I took away from war
for the plight of the Apes was I was
surprised about how haunting that film
felt yeah especially for a Caesar story
- I felt very like who this guy felt
really terrible for him and I'm kind of
hoping we get a similar sense - for Ben
Affleck's Batman
yeah most definitely I mean I haven't
seen every Matt Reeves joint out there
but um you know the things I have seen I
beliefs tinge I thought he's pretty good
and more for the plan of the Apes of the
first time where I really started to
know I didn't respect him before but but
that movie was pretty big in my eyes
like wow okay respect and the things
he's talking about here about you know
getting to know what's going on inside
Bruce Wayne's head and heart I think
that movie does perfectly for Caesar and
locking you into his perspective and all
that like the game he's talking here I
just saw him proved that he can do it
both visually because that that seemed
you know in the cave and everything but
also to matically so uh with any of the
DCU movies at least right now still I'm
always
you know a little cautious in terms of
like I've liked a lot of things people
have said before these movies come out
and I know that their vibe is filmmaker
driven but just reading these quotes I'm
thrilled because yeah I feel like that's
this has the mix of a of a really cool
Batman movie and like you said you know
the more on the street stuff you know
taking down crime I personally would
like to see a little bit more of a
grounded more suspenseful Batman story
and it isn't so much about ah there's a
big sky portal and the entire world is
at stake like you know I would like to
see something that's a bit more you know
personal like that and some of my
favorite comics that have read out
Batman or when he has an internal
monologue going on yeah people really
reference a lot of people hail The Dark
Knight Returns is possibly the best
Batman comic and even though there's an
animated movie they can all the internal
monologue stuff and I think this film I
don't think it needs an internal
monologue of Batman but it would be
fascinating to feel an internal
monologue happening which goes back to
the whole noir sense yes
talking about if you really make this a
visual story with some some room and
some shadows in it like that yeah that
would be perfect I feel like my last
point was the best point that I've made
and all this time I've talked about you
know you want to end on a high note
yeah internal monologue but not have to
hear it I can feel that he's doing yeah
that's kind of over teasers like when
you're watching it I would love that the
fascinate because it's the fascinating
part about Caesar was he was at mocap 8
and you could feel and a what he's
thinking throughout and if they're
capturing bad man with a mask on the
whole time a lot of its gonna have to
come through the eyes and I'm body
length and body language and I'm hoping
that that reisel know how to capture
that as well totally would then act like
not having to do any acting yeah yeah
not even use face always yeah by shadow
on the camera guys Wonder Woman has
topped the DCE use films in terms of
domestic box-office it as beat out Man
of Steel Suicide Squad the movie where
they brought Batman and Superman finally
together finally getting even had Wonder
Woman in it and it taught that one to
Wow what do you know okay it's more than
just marketing if you make a good
movie it could also make more more -
saying that is repeat value
word-of-mouth people will tune in to the
movie even if they didn't really care
before because if my mom didn't go watch
a single DC film in the theatre but she
all these people talking about Wonder
Woman she's like alright I'll go soon
where my mom and sister went to go watch
it last week for a birthday this is what
I mean man it is it Wonder Woman is a
great great example for everything right
now all of our notches the view see you
but all of Hollywood because Wonder
Woman was like I don't know how I want
to use the word underdog but it wasn't
the one that peaked that DC or Warner
Brothers was expecting to be their mega
hit yeah a little bit like uh there were
like 50 million or opening as a risk
women though yeah
did any like movies like we like movies
what was most popular is Batman or
Superman or even Joker she hasn't
punched as many people in the face in
this one I mean yeah but because it's a
great film it's look how much money it's
making it's just shows that it's not all
about making stuff for marketing
purposes yeah it's not about math it's
about spirit too you know yeah and and
if you look at the box office you know
not every good movie hangs around this
huge for weeks on end but if you pay
attention usually this stuff is good it
has some saying power I think stuff like
Rotten Tomatoes and audience scores that
you can read online have a have a lot to
do with people going to a movie now yeah
I mean definitely I don't care if you
agree or disagree with Rotten Tomatoes
I'm talking about the general consensus
it's got an impact it took you know when
you go and see oh the mummy has like a
negative twenty percent profit or
watches you could like slow down and I
mean like that's always happened but now
you can just see so much more feedback
than before spelling because if a
trailer if a trailer does not look that
good to begin with for example the mummy
just didn't look that good didn't look
like a great song to begin with and then
if even for me and you know I saw bummy
opening night we thought mommy opening
night for when you see Rotten Tomatoes
gives it such a low score it's like well
[ __ ] the trailer
look good but then every once in a while
you get like movies with built-in
audiences like BBS or Suicide Squad that
also deliver some pretty damn good
trailers it doesn't matter what the
Rotten Tomatoes score will say sometimes
it'll still make good money but if it's
a great marketing and the movie happens
to be really good and that's their
primary focus is making a great movie
because Wonder Woman is better than the
trailers that sometimes you see movies
with the trailers or errors in the
middle way no I have a that happened I'd
feel like more now than ever you know
because people are really smart about
marketing and Wonder Woman was had great
trailers that the movie was even better
and that's the primary thing so I'm
hoping from here on out that they
stopped worrying about franchise
building they stopped worrying about
their marketing ploys because what
really has made this movie such a
massive global hit except for China
surprising wish you could pick it uh
well you know well that's surprising it
makes logical sense why I thought you
did so well in some other countries but
well in terms of American box office
domestically it surpassed the other ones
for a reason yeah definitely and I don't
know I mean when it comes to film like
this it just makes me really I'm really
happy for DC on this one to be honest
like for all the ones for them to of all
the ones for them to nail you know I
think this is nice and it goes to prove
that people don't care as much about oh
what does this movie have to do with ten
other movies and your universe building
and stuff you know is one good movie is
is always what it's about
even if it's it even if it's a part of a
bigger machine one good movie one good
movie is your stepping stone at a time
and this one few like they finally
focused up and nailed it right so I'm
totally thrilled day to hear this news
I'm so happy gal gadot only got paid
$300,000 to do she really is something
up Adrienne grant game blue though the
next one
she'll be the next one Justice League
and charity shot that so she could have
negotiated with her woman yeah the
problem is he's not a man care
yeah well Wonder Woman - that pretty bag
is gonna go up let's hope so
I mean iron man diamond generally got
paid 500k Man and Iron Man 2 - got paid
10 million and now highest-paid marble
actor right now so yeah let's hope y'all
go duck and start increasing that
paycheck yeah man it's all about money
and forget that eactly
coming back hey hey when Wonder Woman is
a significant character - so well they
all have similar stories you know they
get sick of doing these big-budget
movies they get tired eventually
sometimes the actors gets tired of
working out a lot yeah yeah I don't know
I mean she's she's ex-military right I
don't know if she would ever go higher
we have to still get like a much more
enriched agent martial arts practice for
us alright alright guys well if you're
watching this on YouTube we got a full
exclusive patreon movie news segment
where we cover a few more stories over
there so go check it out wrong if you
want to in the meantime subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell - on Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of Blum
house and like you said go check out our
patreon for exclusive personal rewards
much love a reject nation hash tag
reject nation